there's been a pretty good run and so
while I'm just think about you just came
off of winning so many Grammys and also
all the countries gourds and now you're
at the Oscars how did that come about
well I was asked to come and introduce a
very special performance tonight one
that has Nashville ties so it's special
and I've never I've never been here
before so this is this is kind of well
it was real time the best song one of
the best songs nominee nominated it's
Gillian Welch and David Rawlings they're
performing a song from the new Coen
Brothers movie you know Ballad of Busta
Scruggs so you know I feel connected to
them because they also have a studio
literally down the street from my house
in Nashville I see him all the time
and so it's just cool and very fitting
that I get to introduce so they they
call you up and say case we come to
Hollywood and do a solid um honestly it
was I really don't know how this
happened
it is magically disappeared and I said
of course I would look how did you
possibly a whip up a dress that looks
like this in 100 days or one day well
it's the magicians over
I love this gown so much so fun thank
you before we talk about the the Couture
I got to ask you because we haven't
spoken to you since the Grammys
what was that night light for you and
what has life been like after cotton I
mean just unbelievable I mean I don't
think any human really knows what to do
with all those emotions and that
excitement and just lots of pride lots
of gratitude and then I went straight to
a fast food place and had a giant
cheeseburger a giant fried chicken
sandwich I eat both and fries in my
palates oh my god I love her best time
ever and then yeah I already knew I
liked you but I love you now I was like
y'all I need a car but now and you
deserve that right I did it is will you
tell us a secret about that outfit
I don't know any secrets other than
there's another way that I can put my
arms up how do you pose on the red
carpet I just keep my arms back no it
kinda reminds me of like a fan you know
that's like a little romantic shot going
on yeah I love this color we have
question from Walden AMA native moving
someone asking to pick one of these car
something answer
if you could take a road trip with any
celeb who would it be and where would
you go I would pick I would probably
pick Dolly Parton and we'd go down to
Dollywood and we would like ride all the
rides and eat all the funnel cakes that
sounds like fun
now I just went oh can I come welcome to
come only thirst my bachelorette party
and it was hey it was a hoot it was like
like what you would call a hoot it was
it was we stayed in a cab in there we
like all had matching fanny packs and we
just went all Wed to the log ride and
like all the things in it was so much
fun
[Music]